[Music]
i just read the
sickest catfish story i love catfish
stories tell me more is it a louisiana
catfish
stupid your humor is so clean the kind
of catfish are we talking about here
we're talking about the classic kind oh
the one it's like well that's not a the
bait and switch
the bait in switch
there's this guy right his name is ray
he's 29
meets this girl on tinder
for about a year they have this like
kind of online relationship going she's
always got excuses why not to meet him
up blah blah blah but they're in love
and they started discussing their future
together and everything it's like one of
those things
she's always got some reason why she
can't meet up so then he feels like she
might be uh catfishing
so he hits up that show catfished
and then uh is this the
thing the guy i don't know i don't know
i don't know if it is then
yeah i think i know what it is hits up
the the show catfished and then they do
research they find out the picture is
like stolen from some other chicks so
they know for sure it's not really her
all right so then they tried it was the
guy devastated always like when he's
devastated he was
you look like this yeah he was hurt but
also he wanted to know what the [ __ ]
like who is this person really then so
then uh they you know on one half they
set up the meeting for her to like show
up and uh
they
go to a meeting spot
then the girl comes around the corner
and he is just like
it's a person
that
he knows
and she goes she tells the producers
yeah me and rey
dated a long long time ago
for a year
he cheated on me
and this is my revenge because he wasted
a year of my time
she goes a year for a year i like this
chick that is [ __ ] gee bro but
now she needs she's wasted two years
yeah
so she just wasted an extra year of her
own time
that'll show him
but i've heard that part-time evening
yeah it's part time for her but they
fell back in love all over again no no
she she just was completely [ __ ] with
him the whole year for years but she
must have had some kind of fun like for
oh yeah i'm sure that's a lot of fun
yeah i mean like she she was in it again
that's time well spent and she got to
reveal it on tv are you that's [ __ ]
and then she that's attitude catfish
that's attitude she was like
you know what i thought it was i thought
it was gonna be that episode where the
two guys finally meet their catfish and
they thought it was this hot girl it was
actually
um a chubby mexican boy
[Music]
and then they were just in disbelief
like him and then they were sitting down
in his living room and they're like
it's not him and he goes can you please
do the voice and he goes um i don't know
like
and then they're like oh my god it is
him and they fall in love wait so two of
them were after one chick
two of them got catfished by the same
girl
little chubby mexican boy it was a
mexican why did he do it i was i'm
always interested i just it was on
instagram and it was a snippet if he's a
little mexican boy i think that's just
curiosity he's like i want to see how
far he wasn't that little maybe maybe he
was he looked he was like in his 20s
let's ask him yeah
bring him out bring him back come on out
but when he did the voice he sounded
like a lady wow it was really convincing
huh really good he was hired as a voice
actor the next day
aren't you glad you got married early
enough that you wouldn't be catfished
dude i probably would have been
catfished all over dude all over the
[ __ ] internet on snapchat i'll
probably be catfishing instagram
like where you could see their face it's
really them but then you meet them in
real life they're like shorter or taller
kite fish they lie about their height
yeah i feel like that would probably
happen with with women more like guys
would probably yeah they're like six
feet and then you meet him and he's like
five four i have friends that were hyped
fishing on my space back in the day
because you're you're uh
you could edit your photo to make your
legs and stuff look longer so you're
like oh that looks like a pretty well
that looks long look like all your
pictures are just waist high
or yeah yeah just the art of framing you
do the leg look long or you'll take
pictures like this
like that downward angle oh you know
people use that shoulder boy right there
i was a tall guy you know yeah i totally
had i totally had homies back in the day
on myspace that completely hide fished
what would they do would they be like
i'm five seven and a half but they're
really five six
they wouldn't blatantly ever
i don't think they ever blatantly said
their height but you would never think
based on the photos that they and the
tactfulness they used that they were
like 5-1 oh that's damn oh cause like a
lot of bodybuilder dudes they're pretty
short but they like they look so [ __ ]
big like it's way worse now with filters
i thought you'd say filipinos
[Laughter]
don't do it yeah filters for sure
yeah my space day is like it's just more
about the angle nowadays
double your height like it's just full
like eye filters freaking the [ __ ] out
the eye ones where they go super glassy
and i'm like come on oh you could tell
those are fake do you have goldfish but
what if whatever happened to like you
fall in love with the person you fall in
love with yeah and it's not the picture
that they were romance anymore man and
then you meet them and you're just like
not only are you not a woman you're a
completely different race too that just
goes to show love has no form let me
take a picture you quick joe ryan has an
app where he can turn men into women and
vice versa i don't i make you don't even
need to do that i just undo my hair
so i just want to make an example of
that and just want to be reverse catfish
like they you know fall in love with a
chick that you don't think is that hot
but then you meet them in real life and
they're like way hotter what should we
call that trek you got shrek shrek okay
let's go to candyland reverse catfish
you're like you're not that hot but i
really like your personality and then
you see them in person you're like well
you're hotter than i expected
wow
ultimate that's shallow howled the
soho or would you be too intimidated
because you're way more beautiful than i
expected and i didn't want someone that
intimidating oh that'd be funny
you're like you're too hot you're gonna
leave me you're too you're a dallas
cowboys cheerleader oh no
no way you'll love me yeah that could
happen too no that that's probably
actually pretty common though i've heard
i don't know buddy it's like there's two
you have to compete with so many guys
always after you no way jose yeah no
thank you no way you're way too hot
those twos are way too big the [ __ ] out
of here
so you've skipped an entire like because
you got married so early you skipped the
entire era of like online dating
you married your high school sweetheart
that's like a [ __ ] movie but at the
same time you missed out on so much life
still doesn't yeah
no i did and i'm kind of thankful for it
because i got to see like my buddies go
through all that and like the headaches
they've uh
seen like one of my buddies he was on a
tinder and like you match with this one
girl and he was like dude she's really
hot she's really cool and then she goes
hey like before i date tomorrow like i
need a haircut can you send me four
hundred dollars what the [ __ ] wow cause
she was just [ __ ] baiting him from
the beginning yeah he goes all right and
he just stopped talking to her
but i'm like damn i'd be you know if
that was me i'd probably i'd probably
send that [ __ ] money and a little
song for tip you know so here we go
there's a nice example okay this is a
very candid photo of joe right i thought
that was a girl filter already
a very candid photo of him right i just
took it normal so uh imagine this is who
you meet but you know you were counting
on someone like this
that guy's greek looking or something
hug is that that's you right man i got
catfish it's way too easy now too way
too easy with the technology like yeah
it's scary you could be a guy from spain
look at that dude
you can just create a whole new human
being yeah that's cool what's his voice
what's his voice you have to make a
voice for that
my name is federico
my name is federico if i close my eyes
he's more like hey
a man of few words
because you look so good you don't need
to sing
he's never had to use his vocabulary
before we talk do you think everyone's
going to be so [ __ ] hot in that verse
it's going to be like crazy like how we
even weed people out yeah because you're
in the metaverse and it's like choose
your avatar yeah everyone's having [ __ ]
and once you meet them in person it's
always going to be a let down you're
like oh man you don't look nothing like
your avatar because everything will be
so metaverse related you will never need
to meet him so let's hop back on there
let's let's get back to looking good
again huh what's that doing to our
psychology i think it's gonna be good
wonders no wonders and wonders yeah but
there's actually people that look good
in real life nine eight eight okay yeah
i have mental health issues i'm having
metaverse issues
that's a whole other hotline that's what
i don't know why people think we're
gonna explore the stars we're gonna get
stuck at home and we're gonna be on the
[ __ ] metaverse and we're never gonna
go anywhere yeah dude who wants to be
scientist nowadays
he'll be the only one
you guys want to see any of this nobody
it's great we need people from ours and
they're like no we're going to know that
i'd rather play sims 6.
which is really good though it looks
really [ __ ] good
i forgot
we'll figure it out in the next video
what was i saying man something about
online dating what was he saying better
yet
create an avatar for him like what would
be your catfish i don't even know what
he is he was spanish he's six two give
him a name what's his name frederico
federico what's his last name
rodriguez rodriguez federico tamakama
hamacama oh my gosh okay yeah throw off
the set a little i don't know what that
is did you ever do any online uh dating
or apps you know i i did for like
a day and i immediately jumped down a
day why are you getting harassed huh no
it was just like i just don't care
enough no not at all like it was more so
like i just didn't have the time or the
patience and like the small talk wasn't
something i was interested in can we set
one up for you was it really bad
absolutely not
just wrong
there probably is clever somebody was
using my um my photo for snapchat like
there's a there's a fake account for
snapchat my friend sent me a screenshot
i was like hey did you send me something
on snapchat like i don't even have are
you a little flattered though you're
like i was like no thank you
i thank you so much people in
no big deal i'm debater
to online dating though because there's
the there's the apps oh yeah there's
that right there's mutual friends on
facebook that's old school right like
that's kind of like like older friends
like yeah right and then there's like
instagram
that's a whole different way instagram
is kind of like
the low-key dating platform yeah you
just comment on each other you know it's
just like and you dm each other the more
authentic way of like meeting yourself
right
that's more down to earth huh right
because like when you're on like a
dating platform i feel like it's just
the the preconceived notion of like
we're here to date yeah instead of
getting into somebody so it's like it's
like that feeling is always a little bit
like more pressure but to some people
dating is getting to know someone but on
that level like from the start that's
all it is yeah i think but that to me
that just feels so like i'm here with a
mission but it's just i rather have it
casually even if it isn't the point like
i mean i like it i just want it i just
lied enough i want to lie i just won't
[ __ ] lie to myself
can that fit
all fit yeah
yeah just put the rest of your link
during covid right uh tinder
had so many girls trapping on um [ __ ]
like tinder like during kovid through
all these girls that like
you think you're in a conversation and
then you realize they're just trying to
[ __ ] promote their only fans oh yeah
yeah yeah okay or get a haircut for 400
yeah i'm sure just like put up their
like dating profile but then link their
social media just to get like the
traffic of followers or engagement yeah
well let answer me this when did girls
first start putting their straight up
venmo in their bio that's hilarious i
know people that do that for their
[ __ ] birthday because guys will
[ __ ] pay them
just attention and like see who does
that that's crazy there's this girl that
went to high school with and my wife
showed me this she goes this girl put
her birthday up like it's my birthday
countdown clock or whatever the [ __ ] and
then she put her venmo thing up yeah
like send me money and then like a wish
list of like things that she wanted at
least that's like at least that has
enough you know stuff around it but like
some people just have only their cash
app thing and their venmo and nothing
else i'm gonna start doing it it's your
info you know what i mean it's basically
a [ __ ] panhandler
well but also it's it's it's online
panhandling it's online
yeah that's kind of fire though but it's
under the guise of like chivalry should
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you